[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday September
4th and I'm extremely tired I think I
got bit by a tsetse fly Hank in your
video of last Friday when you were
sitting right here in my house you had
the audacity to imply that I wasn't
proud of the band name mowing the lawns
which is the greatest band name I ever
came up with in my whole long and
storied history of coming up with
hypothetical band names Hank as you know
I'm not a talented musician I can't sing
I don't have any rhythm and I can't play
any musical instruments but I always
really wished I could be in a band and
so I devoted all of my energies to
thinking of band names of which mowing
the lawns is unquestionably the greatest
but Hank it occurs to me that you might
not even know many of the names I've
come up with for the hypothetical bands
I would be in if I didn't suck at music
for instance did you know that if I was
in a death metal band it would be called
bury and the hatchet or that my humerus
punk rock band would be called Kelly and
the Ripa's if I had a band that covered
like old 50s rock standards it would
definitely be called Chester and the
drawers
Hank interesting trivia tidbit about me
I was fully 25 years old when I found
out about chest of drawers as a phrase
someone was talking to me and they're
like do you have a nice chest of drawers
in your room and I was like do you mean
Chester drool Oh chest of drawers yes of
course
Hank if I was the bass guitarist for a
children's literature rock band we would
totally be called Judy in the bloom's my
art rock band would be called
Schroedinger and the maybe dead cats
okay like if Michael Jackson made a
comeback and he decided to make a
comeback with a band and for some reason
he decided to include me in that band I
would want us to be called Jaco and the
lanterns my gospel group Holly and the
whoo use okay that's all the blank in
the blanks I got but I do have some
other band names that I'm pretty fond of
for instance if I had a ska band you
know what it would be called the moby
moby dick tones doesn't even it doesn't
even make any sense I just like saying
the mopey mopey dick tones moby moby
dick tones mo mo dick tones mo mo dick
tones moby moby dick toe
if I was a rapper my rap name would be
MC 1100 or in Roman numerals MC MC Roman
numeral jokes anybody anybody MC MC no
okay if I was in a noise band we'd be
from California and we'd be called all
loud on the Western Front and if I was
in a nerdcore band we'd be called
negative sub cubed equals awesome
speaking of negative suck cubed equals
awesome Hank great job turning the suck
of all the Brotherhood to calm problems
into the awesome that is the new
brotherhood to calm the wikki wikki
wikki is back my pants are on fire and
the site isn't going down except maybe
like a couple times late at night and
only then for a minute so just be
patient Hank thanks to you and Katherine
for visiting us last week the Yeti and I
had a great time I've got to go stick my
head in a vat of cold water to try to
wake up but I'll see you tomorrow
singing yes